hey leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zu diesem video es ist super
und ich fange mal video einfach im auto
an aber das hat einen ganz bestimmten
grund und zwar habe ich mich fürs
heutige video t
als frau mit der telekom zusammen getan
und habe mir eine challenge gesetzt
nämlich dass sich sämtliche aufnahmen
nicht in meiner wohnung machen
das sagten ganz bestimmten grund die
telekom hat die social flat
herausgebracht alle details dazu werde
ich mich später nochmal erzählen im
prinzip kann man damit aber unbegrenzt
im internet surfen auf plattformen wie
linda watson gramm also wirklich alles
ich habe schon ganz bestimmten waren
zwar hätte ich mich mit mikey treffen
kennt ihr bestimmt aus meinen videos
michael adrien oder unstable stylist wie
er sich nennt und der wird mit mir
zusammen ein makeover machen das heißt
er wird mich komplett schminken und wird
versuchen nicht wie eine frau aussehen
zu lassen stelle ich mir mega schwierig
vor aber wir schaffen das auf jeden fall
deshalb war traue ich ihm einfach mal
dann werde ich selbst noch ein bisschen
nachhelfen mit photoshop face tun und
was mir so in die hände kommt und dann
haben wir hoffentlich fotos mit denen
wir ein täterprofil von mir als frau aus
starten können ich würde sagen springen
auf direkt daneben ein bisschen mit so
ich bin angekommen bei mike i wer
bereits die gerade schon hin sofort ja
gemeint er wird jetzt das weiblichste
make-up wasser machen kann für mich
machen
das brauchen wir glaube ich los geht's
was ist das video wie soll daraus eine
frau werden
das ist herr minister in der phase 3 2 1
was sie schon immer von oben
das ist gut
wir haben nochmal zurück gewechselt zu
echter adamsapfel aus dem tristen
revealing und entwickeln auf jeden fall
bei dieser ganzen sache so viel passion
dafür was viele frauen täglich machen
mission erfolgreich
danke schön nochmal für deine ganze
hilfe und die zeit die wir eingefahren
zwei stunden sollte zwei stunden okay
das make-up art gesehen ich würde sagen
wir gucken uns gleich die finalen bilder
an ich drehe es aber mit kelly und
sturmgewehr zu denen gehen und ich
glaube ich stehe einfach schon mal ein
account zeitgleich zu die ersten
eindrücke bin mega gespannt und mega
gehalt ob es funktionieren wird aber
dass unsere wohnung das ist mein account
ich habe mich leider gehört mit 20 jahre
alt 178 alle schreiben das hin das ist
diese klassische kinder verschrieben
hier
das zweite bild und leute ich war
wirklich fünf minuten auf kinder fünf
minuten mit den verlangt und ich hatte
99 plus live also dass alle leute
das heißt ich werde jetzt ein paar
leuten schreiben und dann sehen wir uns
und gucken was sie mir schreiben und was
ich ihnen schreibe und was für gespräch
entstehen wird sehr lustig ich würde
auch nicht sagen
nächster tag ich bin drauf unterwegs mit
sebastian und jakob und ja ich kann nur
so viel sagen es ist echt was rum
gekommen ich habe es wirklich nicht
glauben können wie viele leute mir
überhaupt likes geben und so und wir
werden gleich hab ich mir überlegt ein
kindergeld account aus meinem account
machen das heißt ich kann sehen exakt
wie viele leute mehr likes gegeben haben
innerhalb von ungefähr 24 stunden auf
meinem girl account leide ich glaube es
wird richtig krass und bürger schätzen
was glaubst du wie viel also du meintest
man kann er am tag des streiks gebe aber
so dass zwei tage bis 80 mal also das
schon eine gute like rote ich würde
sagen wenn köln essen großstadt so du
bist viel angezeigt ich sag mal so du
hast zu 300 like sebastian sagt 300 like
sind 24 stunden jakob was sagst du auch
das ist so krank alter als ob 200 leute
mich der like innerhalb von einem tag
ich würde sagen ich platziere mich mal
in der mitte von euch beiden ich sag 250
der gewinner kriegt nicht sehr gut okay
leute hier in diesem wunderschönen
panorama
wir sind am decksteiner weiher in köln
werden wir uns jetzt anschauen wie viele
leute mir insgesamt likes gegeben haben
auf kinder ihr seht es schon
ich kriege die ganze zeit nachrichten
rein ich habe 53 matches und ich habe
einfach nur also nur mit dem free
account einfach so nach rechts gewicht
die ganze zeit so viele leute haben wir
leicht gegeben und ich kann jetzt bin
ich rüber gehe ihr seht keine likes mehr
kann ich keine leicht mehr verteilt
deshalb ist es glaube ich an derzeitig
geht all-in für dieses video ton mehr
hinter gold aber bevor es losgeht leute
kleiner cliffhanger von mir erzählen
noch die details zur stream an social
web also wie gesagt ihr könnt ihr noch
bis zum 5 september kostenfrei buchen
für 24 monate und danach kostet die vier
euro 95 und was man machen kann mit das
thema inzwischen fährt habe ich auch
schon mal kurz angeschnitten ihr könnt
auf diensten wie tender twitter facebook
instagram whatsapp ohne eure daten um zu
verbrauchen surfen das heißt ihr könnt
euer datenvolumen faktisch in meinem
fall zumindest ich kann das nicht mehr
auf bauch und hab ja auch die anderen
stream und optionen und dadurch bin ich
unterwegs ich hab eigentlich 24 gb
datenvolumen von ich kann es nicht mehr
auf braucht und das sind so die
absoluten first wenn man seinen
datenvolumen nicht mehr aufbauen kann
aber deshalb ist eine geile sache ich
könnte zum beispiel auch meinen youtube
videos on the way einfach hochladen ohne
meinen datenvolumen zu verbrauchen ist
es wirklich mega fresh und deshalb
stellt das auch gerne vor dann schon
noch mal die telekom für die
unterstützung und lasst uns schauen wie
viele leicht zu bekommen hat leute
leider leider leider kann ich kein team
bei gold holen für meinen account ich
habe gerade die ganze zeit probiert hat
mir sogar eine neue apple id erstellt
aber ich habs gerade gekauft wie weit er
dabei und er ist einfach auf mein
reguläres konto gebucht
und jetzt kann ich nicht mehr ändern das
heißt wir können leider nur in die
nachrichten reinschauen es tut mir mega
light vielleicht haus die noch einmal
auf instagram oder sowas falls ich doch
hinbekomme und zeigt euch dann wieder
leicht bekommen haben mit dem account
aber ich würde sagen
24 stunden lang das heißt zwei mal
zweiter das ist aufgebaut ist habe ich
jetzt verbracht mit meinem girl account
wir schauen uns hier noch mal an laura
20 universität zu köln 178 alle
schreiben dass hier hin neu hier und ich
habe genial ich habe zwei rosa herzchen
diese süßen frauen herzchen habe ich
gewusst hätte ist quasi nicht verstehen
können dass ich eigentlich ein mann wenn
ich finde schon dass es echt krass
aussieht also was möglich ist was man
für eine veränderung überhaupt machen
kann hat echt so ein bisschen meine nein
meint gebot dass mein account natürlich
komplett
[Musik]
ok dann schauen wir einfach mal leute
ihr seht es oben links 99 plus likes die
hatte ich wie gesagt nach fünf minuten
nach echten fünf minuten hatte ich 99
plus leicht das spricht eigentlich dafür
dass wahrscheinlich 1000 gleich was wäre
so krass eigentlich und man weiß nicht
genau wie oft man vision kann pro tag
aber ich habe 57 matches 57 ist was und
von denen haben ja auch mega viele
geschrieben ich muss natürlich aufpassen
dass es zeige super vielen achten habe
ich bekomme ich würde sagen wir gucken
uns jetzt einfach mal ein paar an die
erste nachricht ich bekommen habe sich
ganz neu war
du bist ganz sicher eine frau kann man
mehr von mir sehen so richtig genervt
und erstens wieso menschen mit dann
zweitens war es der einzige so viel kann
ich jetzt schon sagen der einzige der
das geschrieben auch niemand sonst hat
gesagt bist du nicht einzeln man also
entweder waren die alle zu taktfolge und
wollten mich nicht verletzen aber es war
der einzige mann der das geschrieben
aber das thema polizei wie gesagt ich
habe so eine standard nachricht gemacht
und zwar war das team mit 2 y und diesen
grinsenden smiley weil ich dachte ich
schreibe und das war natürlich die
einzige antwort der herr der mich
angeschrieben hat heißt jason und
bewirbt sich kann euch das wird ne zeit
aber der ist so eine maschine der ist am
ende dass sie es bitte mach ich fertig
eigentlich gerade gesehen also der ist
wirklich so eine maschine testen wenn du
siehst mir leid also ein spaß aber er
hat mir dann auch nicht mehr geschrieben
hat mir geschrieben ich habe ihn gestern
abend beantwortet keine antwort bisher
auch hier eine sehr schöne nachricht ja
hoops hey bist du neu in köln oder auf
kinder swp wieder bei dem zwei oops i
lon und dem gbagbo oft ändert eine
antwort na ja wir haben auch leute
diesen sehr direkt bock mal kennen zu
lernen meine antwort schreibt navi geht
doch mal zu treffen schreibt wir zwei
nachrichten zweimal direkt treffen
wollen ich glaube aber laura ist ein
bisschen ein bisschen zu viel
ich habe jede menge geschrieben
wir haben natürlich auch ein paar
richtige konversation jetzt wird die uci
leute einfach mal vor ort hey du hey wie
gehts dir schöne fotos dankeschön gut
und wir ja auch frei heute und du warum
sagst du mir das so frei hast wird sich
so auch fester ferien ich wegen nerv
eingeklemmt in nacken was geht heute bei
dir denn nicht so gute besserung habe
nichts vor und dann dachte ich mir so
konnte versucht das warten hat dieses
englische geschichte schreibt direkt
soll nicht vorbei kommen und du hilfst
mir bei der heilung so funktioniert das
nicht
es geht mir ein bisschen schnell also so
bist einfach zu gut ich nehme das als
das wäre es die komplimente aller zeiten
ich bin einfach zu gut wenn nicht jetzt
raus danke schön an sich an dieser
stelle mega nacht habe ich hier bekommen
sie jetzt einfach selbst also was soll
ich sagen da habe ich auch auf
englischen kontakt ab beschreibt myphone
ist so bettink ins kosovo
ich schicke würde genervt und ich dachte
mir so kommen durch nach beschrieben
keine antwort mehr zum glück ich muss
auch wirklich sagen ich habe von den
unterschiedlichsten leuten also wirklich
alle ethnien und persönlichkeiten körper
war jeder hat mir geschrieben wirklich
komplett verschieden schließlich mit
dieser person laura witte so wirklich
existieren würde so neben mir
das wäre das für gestört ist wer also
wirklich hat mir mega spaß gemacht
dieses videos es war so ein richtiges
projekt irgendwie so mit dem umstyling
alles draußen drehen und so das war
wirklich eine leiste erfahrung und ich
habe mich viel spaß dabei gehabt checkt
unbedingt in den nächsten tagen meine
instagram account arbeit dann werde ich
versuchen das noch irgendwie
herauszufinden wie viele leipzig
bekommen habe wer wirklich zu schade
wenn ich es nicht wissen könnte damit
ich aber erstmal sagen danke schön dass
ihr dabei war ich hoffe ihr fand das
video genau so lustig wie ich und checkt
unbedingt und in der beschreibung die
links ab zur telecom social et leichtes
produkt und wir sind zwar nicht ein
video tschüss